welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and apparently
Ghostface is the only person on this
planet who can bring a knife to a
gunfight and win the trailer for Scream
6 just dropped and we've got a lot to
unpack here I still have so many
questions after seeing this trailer like
could Stu mocker return will they kill
off legacy cast member Courtney Cox this
time how did Kirby survive her attack
and most importantly what's your
favorite scary movie today I'm taking
you frame by frame through the new
Scream 6 trailer to cover all the
details you might have missed I want to
get this breakdown out to you guys as
fast as possible so if there's any
missing Easter eggs that I've had to cut
for time let me know in the comments if
you want to see a follow-up video the
trailer opens up with a drone shot of
New York City from above the first film
in the franchise to take place in NYC
Sam and Tara run breathless into a
bodega begging for help in true New York
Fashion this dude is pissed that they're
cutting him in line in the bottom right
corner behind the counter there's a
poster that reads do not serve this man
with a grainy black and white photo of a
man is it just me or does it look like
he's wearing classic serial killer
glasses it doesn't look like my Prime
Suspect foreign Schumacher so it might
just be the mystery second killer or a
random guy who has nothing to do with
the movie at all Ghostface bust through
the door and takes out the cranky dude
in line it looks like this lady listened
to Sydney's advice from the first movie
instead of running away from the killer
she runs straight out the front door
despite being warned that the bodega
owner is armed via a sign directly over
the owner's head ghost face is shot at
but of course he Dodges the bullets
better than Keanu in The Matrix and
manages to stab that guy too Sam and
Tara have to crawl on their hands and
knees over broken glass to escape but
Ghostface sees them just before the
camera goes black next Sam appears to be
talking to a therapist confessing that
she couldn't escape her darkest secret
that her father was the first ghost face
Billy Loomis if you recall from Scream 5
Sam was experiencing hallucinations of
her father and ultimately killed her
Ghostface ex-boyfriend saying never [__]
with the daughter of a serial killer
when she says it followed me here you
see her holding this new ghost face
cracked bloody mass inside of a zipper
jacket which combined with the clue I
talked about in my Scream 6 poster
breakdown really has me convinced that
it belongs to Stu marker not only is his
DOT on the poster a different color than
the other ghost faces Matthew Lillard
has long been hinting at his return to
the franchise actually it's not so much
hinting as it is him outright saying it
you didn't die at the end of scream 1.
unless in scully's before you start
calling me a conspiracy theorist hear me
out Matthew Lillard actually made a
blink and you'll miss it Cameo as an
uncredited extra on screen too he
apparently visited the set one day
during filming and Wes Craven thought it
would be funny to put a wig on him and
stick him in the background of a scene
see that guy behind Randy Meeks with
bleach blonde hair and glasses that's
Matthew Lillard and many fans like me
have a headcanon that this was stew and
disguise still stalking his victims
after his supposed death in an interview
back in 2009 Matthew Lillard confirmed
that he was supposed to return as one of
the killers in Scream 3. he said well
the funny thing is I was supposed to
come back for the third one nobody knows
this but the the third one they had
written in uh me to be the killer the
third one now how is that going to be
justified because you were here to be TV
on the head what it took a TV is that
what it was that's how I died so
theoretically I was you could have been
from jail I was masterminding this kind
of
um
this this attack against Sydney Ned's
character that's straight from the
violent murdery horse's mouth if he
really was supposed to come back and
scream three at one point that means
that his character was technically still
alive in Wes Craven's mind too after
Lillard tweeted asking his followers if
they really believed that Stu was dead
many fans believed that he'd return in
Scream five but if you think about it it
makes even more sense that they're
bringing him back now without needs
Campbell or David Arquette's Dewey Finn
you gotta have another major Legacy
comeback like Stu you know what time it
is Bam it's geology time geology is a
16-time award-winning personalized
skincare company recognized in Hikes
birdie Men's Health Esquire and ask men
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews and now they offer products for
whatever you need just take a quick 30
second diagnostic quiz and geology
figures out your whole routine for you
geology creates simple and effective
skincare and Hair Care routines
customized just for you with ingredients
that are proven to work no matter what
you're trying to take care of for Hair
Care use LG's co-wash a specially
formulated cream cleanser that removes
buildup and cleanses hair without the
harsh ingredients of typical shampoo
geology also has body washes that are
free of harsh ingredients smell great
and are refillable for skin care geology
can protect your skin from environmental
stresses with vitamin C and euphyrilic
serum keep your skin looking young and
healthy and then a bit of dermatologist
tested aluminum-free deodorant right now
for a limited time geology is hooking
our viewers up with an absolutely
Bonkers offer if you use code Rockstar
70 they'll give you an additional 70 off
of their award-winning skincare trial
set we did the math and that's five
products for just 15 on top of that you
can take an additional 30 bonus offer on
one of their brand new skin hair and
body products of your choice when you
add it to your trial to get started just
click the link in the description next
we see a glimpse of one of ghostface's
potential future victims actor lyanna
liberato's new character Carly we also
get a glimpse of Devon Dakota's new
character Allison here with Mindy and
Sam Hayden Panettiere is the Legacy
character where certain is making a
comeback after her survival from
ghostface's attack in Scream 4 was
confirmed in in Scream 5 it was clear
that she'd be one of the final girls in
Scream 6. Kirby's right she Gales Sam
and Tara do share a very special kind of
certain history but the question is
which of these final girls or guys will
survive could Kirby actually be the
second ghost face or is Ghost Face here
to make sure that she dies this time
then we see a ghost face Banksy with his
most famous catchphrase spray painted on
the wall if you've ever been to NYC you
know his artwork is like everywhere her
Vio tells us that this ghost face isn't
like the other ghost faces again which
makes me think that it could be stew
because he was the very first he'd have
an in-depth knowledge of every single
ghost face that came after him their
kills their motivations their failures
if he's been biting his time waiting for
the right moment to strike he'd have
quite the collection of research behind
his attacks Tara Kirby Mindy Chad Gail
and Dermot mulroney's Williams enter a
creepy ass basement Mindy's wearing a
shirt that says lavender Menace a
radical lesbian feminist Society from
New York in the 1970s Chad's wearing a
Blackman University sweatshirt which
coupled with footage of what looks like
a dorm room later on in the trailer
makes me think that this is the
fictional College where he and his
sister go Gail realizes that they've
walked into ghosts face a shrine filled
with memorabilia from all his past kills
this police uniform could belong to any
number of victims from the Woodsboro
Police Department it could be Dewey's
Hoss's or Perkins the latter two being
from Scream 4. the bloody gray
sweatshirt belongs to Olivia Morris
killed in screamed 4. the stab in the
upper left-hand corner of the shirt
matches where Olivia was first stabbed
by Ghostface that mask is from Scream
2's Windsor College Stage production of
Oedipus and that sun prop is where Derek
was killed on stage in Scream 2.
starting with the left-hand side of this
treasure room first we have a portrait
of Kirby Jill's plaid shirt from Scream
4 the clapboard from the set of stab 3
from Scream 3 the frying pan that hit
The Bodyguard Steve Stone the fax
machine that lured Tom prints into an
explosive trap Nancy's pistol Debbie
Nancy's suit Billy's blood soap t-shirt
stew smoking jacket and finally the TV
that crushed do on the right we see
boyfriend Steve's letterman jacket AKA
ghostface's very first on-screen kill
Tatum's outfit from the night the garage
crushed her and her boobs a baseball cap
outfit of Kenny Browns a display case of
Gail's published Works including
Hollywood horror true story of stab 3
knife of Doom knife of the Hunter and
Clock of Doom a Woodsboro High School
flag and another display case filled
with stab 3 merge a knife a poster DVDs
and of course a mask Sam walks towards
the lineup of statues angling herself
towards the statue of her father Billy
Loomis front and center in his own glass
case from left to right we also see
statues of Richie Amber Jill Charlie
Billy Stew Nancy slash Debbie Mickey and
Roman aka the previous ghost faces in
the next group shot we see two more new
characters Jack Champions Evan and Josh
cigar as David over in Gail's spacious
New York apartment she finds herself in
an all too familiar situation dealing
with a mass murderers teasing on the
phone aka the foundation of every single
one of these movies she reminds the
caller that this ain't her first scream
Rodeo Buckaroo but surprise Ghostface is
already in the apartment he reveals
himself behind her bookcase and Below
him you can see a copy of Gail's book
ghost face returns he menaces her with
his iconic bloody knife white before his
attack but Gail is packing some heat so
she's ready to shoot her attacker in the
head a very smart move that she
definitely learned is the best way to
deal with these dudes from previous
experience always aim for the head
though maybe wait until you have a clear
shot and don't do it blind through the
door we have some more shots of
potential victims in this film put in
precarious situations chatting with the
killer on the phone and even facing off
in some sort of elaborate movie theater
set where ghost face is presumably
showing off his favorite kill Clips the
amateur footage behind Sam actually
looks like it could be Ghost Face home
movies which sounds terrifying my guess
is that this happens during the climax
of the film but who knows the killer
could just be re-watching the stab
movies over and over and over again like
Richie now we're back on the subway car
we saw on the teaser trailer and there
are ghost bases everywhere you can check
out my breakdown of this train scene in
the video I already put out breaking
down the teaser trailer and poster let
me know what you think in the comments
about Stu's potential return follow me
on Instagram and Twitter whitneypuppy
follow me Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis event
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]